you need words to think
the fewer words you have the less
thinking you can do
and of course that's the entire point of
restricting our available vocabulary
down to just a few
sanitized grunts and that's where we're
headed
fast you may have noticed almost nothing
you were allowed to say 10 years ago
could you say now
the cleveland indians for example
they're being eliminated
under our new system it's hard to keep
track of what words you're allowed to
use even hillary clinton
painfully sensitive an earnest methodist
violated speech codes one she probably
supports
as recently as a few years ago
i have a lot of experience dealing with
men who sometimes
get off the reservation and the way they
behave and how they speak
hillary clinton's mad at men obviously
and has every reason to be
but those men got off the reservation
now if she'd check with the university
of michigan the speech codes there
mrs clinton would know the phrase off
the reservation is now a form of hate
speech
that university has helpfully created a
words matter
task force to keep track of which words
you're allowed to use
which ones you're allowed to keep in
your head what thoughts you're allowed
to have
take a look at the list you'll learn
that brown bag is no longer acceptable
neither is the phrase
low man on the totem pole there are a
lot of words like that
curiously the word picnic is also
verboten
and that's no picnic